hi this is caitlin here at comic-con
with darth vader hello Darth you do look
much more approachable in the pink so
basically you're here recruiting
absolutely when telling them that we
have puppies and cookies and that works
it seems to be yes you get like I'm a
little bit of pent-up rage when you have
to be friendly all day and you're in
your pink robes all about pent-up rage
can you tell me a little bit about your
costume well this is a stab at steampunk
and so how do you make steampunk a
little more extreme let's add a dinosaur
after a few frantic weeks we finally got
this designed to work and here we are
yesterday I showed up with a steampunk
frock coat and top hat that had more
metal than fabric and it was killing me
so I said all right let's go with a
tropical version so i got the pith
helmet in the indiana jones shirt and
it's working for me today that's awesome
I really I'm impressed I address as
lumpy Space Princess from the show
adventure time on Cartoon Network have
you seen any more of her here at
comic-con actually I haven't i've been
here since the preview night i haven't
seen any lumpy space princess is so i'm
really really happy because i was just
like yes I'm original oh I think you're
the only lumpy Space Princess at
comic-con 2012 and I'm here with the
great googly woogly otherwise known as
tiny instead of being your typical like
spider-man or Superman or any cartoon
character I just want to be myself and
this is me the great googly woogly so um
do you wear any of these pieces in
everyday life i cost him about 30 or 40
days a year 30 or 40 days a year wow and
is this costume or something than your
regular year-round costume well like I
mean it depends on the event but there's
santacon and burning man and then of
course Halloween
st. Patrick's Day so I've got a good
leprechaun I've got multiple Santa's
I've got I mean I've got hundreds of
costumes so well that's awesome thank
you so much for taking the time to talk
to us and for more coverage of comic-con
please check out wired com